all right guys we're here in quala
Lampur the capital city of Malaysia look
how beautifully it is designed excellent
infrastructure one of the best I would
say in Southeast Asia and we're here
with the main man himself the da
Powerhouse fli Boran how you doing prob
okay Mah it's really nice to have you
here brother hijab we're here in the
heart of quam po the capital of Malaysia
and this is these are twin towers and
these are the tallest buildings
tallest twin tower buildings one of I
think if not the in the world qu L does
have its fair share of high rises you
could say k lur is one of the most
developed uh Muslim
cities in the world in fact you could
make an argument thato developed
probably right behind Dubai and Abu
Dhabi and Doha so where are we today we
are now at m c the one of the most
iconic M here in Malaysia actually and
it's just located beside the prime
minister's office and alham we get a
chance to pray in the M right how do you
find it it's beautiful let's take a look
at it a little
bit what's interesting yeah what's
interesting about MOS they receive about
10 to 20,000 visitors or tourists every
day and most of them are non-muslims so
this is putro JIA mosque it's the most
famous mosque in Malaysia very beautiful
architecture I'd like to know more about
where they've been inspired from dramas
cuz it looks like a mix of different
areas of inspiration very interesting
huge Dome they do the mosque tour here
you can see over
there all the details of the
architecture very
interesting about to start an event here
we got the main man
mashallah we got the brothers here he
behind the scenes
yeah they're announcing the
champ hi we're in Malaysia right now
okay you see how tall I am in this
country I'm taller than usual it is it
is come here come here oh my God look at
this Okay so we've got brother Li
masallah who's the uh director of the
IDT Center one of the big centers in
southeast Asia I want to ask you Dr Li
how did you get to the position that
you're in uh how did you become Muslim
in the first place I was born as a
Buddhist Buddhist in a Buddhist family
yeah um I became a Christian at the age
of 13 so I was in Christianity for
nearly 14 years how do I get to know
Islam one of my friend who brought a
debate with be that and Swagat I do not
know much anything about Islam but
through this debate it opened my mind to
do research and
study uh about comparative religion and
one of the things that attracted me most
is the verse in the Quran inah bakar
chapter number 2 ver
255 and this is the most special ayat
for me the most special ayat why because
this ayat actually teaches me how to
differentiate who is God who is not God
who is divine who is not Divine this is
AI yeah who is Almighty who is not
Almighty so What's this called Nas Lama
Nasi Lama is my favorite ReliOn food why
I've had randang I've had it's it has a
delicate mixture of you know
spice um and also it's got the carb
element I like the fact that they put an
egg in there it's a good mix yeah they
put an egg in there but it's just the
the nature of the the sauce here is it
too spicy bro no not at all how do you
find the sambal the spicy sauce it's
nice it's very good okay I think most
people will be able to tolerate it yeah
nice this is the second time you're
having the same Nama yes I've tried the
randang which is you could say the most
famous dish mhm the beef one yeah the be
now but I prefer this by by far okay
nice cool so what do you have to say
about uh this is your final day uh we
are already at the airport living for
London so what do you have to say about
Malaysia BR Malaysia is a beautiful
country it's it's one of the countries
that honestly if someone's had enough of
the West and want some Muslim
alternative this should be at the top of
their list they have to at least visit
it and see what it's about before making
a decision cuz a lot of people just had
enough of the West now they don't want
to live in Europe anymore because of
what's happening in school systems or
whatever and they're looking for
Alternatives so we've spoken about I
mean I've done a bit of touring in uh in
Pakistan we spoke about that in uh Islam
Abad it's an alternative Riyad yes Dubai
Abu Dhabi yes they're all fine
alternativ
do but qu is definitely up there with
Captain AI a pilot Allah a high rank
pilot I was going to say to you that I
was going to ask you a question but
before I do so let me explain my mental
reasoning so I always think about the
worst case scenario yeah in life and in
general I I just like to do that so one
time I thought about what if I want a
plane okay okay but if I'm on a plane
and the pilot dies okay it has a heart
attack right right so someone's going to
have to land a plane right
yes if this happened this worst case
scenario happened yeah what
what a lay man can do to land the plane
or to safely land a plane if everyone
everyone
dies well first I would suggest to find
another pilot on
board yeah yeah yeah okay that's someone
who's been training yes fine yeah once
that is
done uh I think the ATC will play a very
key role here okay yeah cuz they're
going to guide you yes what do I do well
you have the control column in front of
you okay it's it's like playing a game
okay put it yeah put it simply G okay
it's like playing a game play game yes
yeah so you push forward the nose goes
down yes you pull it back the nose goes
up okay and then left and right sure
what about the wheels how do you get
them down is there a button to press yes
there's a specific button that puts the
wheels down Al so and then I just put it
down yes and then and then you got to
slow the aircraft now you're slowing the
aircraft you got to put the flaps in yes
so that's another lever yeah yeah so you
you're dealing with this one or this one
both okay okay so now that's where the
skill comes in okay so now you're
holding this and you're holding the
trust levers to slow down the
Y and then you're putting down the flaps
and the landing gear as
well did I did I lose you somewhere do
you know what I would do in this
situation uhhuh I I I'm listening to
what you're saying but I would say
listen we need to this is a Twan job it
it is it's a two-man job yeah yes three
is too many yeah normally it's a two men
job yeah I'd say listen let's get
someone who's most confident in doing
I'll bring them in give them two tasks I
get two tasks he's he's responsible for
pulling this thing I'm responsible for
pushing this thing correct something
that would be good yeah yes because you
need you need someone to help you out
yeah so like I'll have half the task
he'll have half the task ATC I'll tell
them listen ATC we've got two people
here yeah yes and then I'm going to take
task one and two he's going to task
three and four yes so this could save
someone's life maybe one day it good
this video here this video here could
save somebody's life inshah all right
then with that I'll conclude